hey reject nation how you doing Greg
here Andrew here from the movie source
channel my close friend Andrew Gordon
here with us today I thought this would
be fun andrew has recently binge watched
all the MCU films I did in chronological
order to Greg's right oh yeah
chronological so you start with cap I
started with Captain America the First
Avenger and then on every single
flashback clip I feel from movie to I'm
just like in the presence of the story
you know where that next place I went in
chronological order I did start with
Captain America the First Avenger I
worked all the way up to Thor Ragnarok I
couldn't do black panther because it was
in theaters I mean I just recently so I
guess I counted that but everything else
I did we do this segment now called
trailers revisited and for you guys who
don't know what we do here it's pretty
simple it's pretty much in the title we
determine how accurately portrayed a
movie is based off the trailer that came
out tone if it's spoiler if ik whatnot a
lot of requests came in for age of
Ultron under wise relevant let's check
out the first trailer for age of Ultron
right I do it's called teaser but it's
also like the official trailer yeah two
minutes exactly right
you'll never see me coming
everyone sweet for mercy vibranium
not to protect the world but you don't
want to change
your old puppets strings string
yeah so so much darker Pinocchio
this looks like a dark psychological war
epic yeah I was excited when they came
over first all that yeah
oh yeah that's right
Oh
whoo
[Music]
I don't wish we got that movie that just
seems so much yeah I'm watching the
trigger it makes me laugh because this
ain't the five there's definitely some
moments of panic
obviously spoiler alert ya know an age
of Ultron obviously we get and ended the
world scenario that we're told being
told and shown that's happening with
sokovia following but the tone of the
movie is very jokey and three ones
quippy as hell and even ultron it's like
that i think the fundamental issue I
mean I just re-watched age of Ultron I
still enjoyed it I think the team
camaraderie is there like Joss Whedon
nails the Avengers he gets it but in
terms of this movie and what this
trailer saw me is that Ultron he's going
to be impossible to beat and basically
you know what they're showing us here
again is they have never seen anything
like this threat level and then when you
see Ultron the film and means not that
menacing he jokes a lot more which I do
like the humor in the film but that's
the fundamental flaw in the movie that
Joss Whedon messed up was all Tron like
he never felt this menacing and
throughout the film I never thought for
a moment he was gonna beat the Avengers
now he seemed like less basically off
this trailer it feels like it's gonna be
like a philosophical villain that's
gonna kind of challenge the whole morale
of what it means to be a superhero
for mercy the stakes feel even higher in
the trailer than the actual movie one
thing that age of Ultron does have
suffer from because they're gonna be
wrong the first time I say age of Ultron
I didn't really care for it I watch it
again a second time later on and I
actually enjoyed it more I still saw
plenty of its flaws it is still is way
too compact with the film being compact
and having a lot of unnecessary stuff
like even in the trailer you get hints
of it it's weird because when you watch
the movie it feels unnecessary some of
the things that take place here they got
teasers of the ballet scene and then the
gurney of black widows past you got Thor
coming out of the water which doesn't
really play and even into the later
films that's just all set up for a
future installment and then he even got
the shot of like cap shield all
destroyed looks like he's dead another
moment in the trailer that plays for a
good trailer but when you watch the
movie you're like oh none of that really
matters it actually that's just a
nightmare sequence but ya know but I
think one of the things that I loved in
this trailer were the facial expressions
a lot like from you know Bruce Banner
you see like on his face how dark and
like how he's really struggling with
being all kin like how you can tell like
probably possibly actually gave him a
nightmare visions I really believe that
facial expressions can be so powerful in
scenes that you know just driving what
the characters are really feeling as
opposed to just giving us a bunch of
dialogue and exposition and I think
that's what sells the darkness of this
trailer is so many of the facial
expression images they yeah they're the
right images they get is just I think it
would have been cool to get a fun
Avengers exciting first movie that
Marvel's Avengers Assemble and is going
to be and this one is like really like
really dark with humor with an attack
and we're not saying dark automatically
just fixes the film tonally like this
really works from this trailer
especially with the way the visual
cinematography is it looked like it
would be a dark I fell
you know whereas the first Avengers has
a much brighter look yeah that's got
more even though it is again end of the
world sterner it's got more of a fun bye
yeah which is appropriate for your first
eat mashup movie one thing this trailer
also does too is it it has this vibe
that oh man the Avengers are all turning
on each other which does kind of happen
in the movie cuz I like that the movie
starts off where they're all already a
team that's assembled and they kind of
fall apart a little bit towards the end
of the movie especially with the whole
in terms of the tone though everything
about this is the tone the dread the
worry the fear none of that's really
present in the actual film itself if the
movie was more like this like you could
still have humor within the context of
its characters and their dialogue and
whatever but if it felt a little bit
more focused and grounded because this
communicates a rather simple premise
Ultron's created and he means to take
over and destroy the Avengers and the
Avengers have to unite but it's become
in a very perilous and dangerous journey
even like the Hulkbuster versus Iron Man
scene is played out in the trailer as
this like a heavy weighty dramatic
moment but when you watch that scene
it's more like this is fun and cool and
and Tony Stark still may be funny or
they could he's budget in so to sleep a
lot of this stuff just plays out fun
what this movie could have used is some
dramatic weight I think you've got a
major point like when Yuri watch the
Battle of sokovia there it's quit after
quit you'll never never
well were you napping you guys this is
the end of the look I mean you should
have a little humor before you dime I'm
with you but if it's every single scene
like let's have quick the other person
in a moment and like moments where we
about to die you want action scenes to
be emotionally driven not quick driven
yeah Ultron does not really have that
sense of menace that we all thought like
this like philosophical terminator I
think that's probably the biggest
letdown is how old traumas handled
because in this trailer you're like oh
my god the greatest MCU villain is gonna
come like at this point yeah thank you
really just nailed that they're like
when you rewatch term the Terminator the
first one from 84 when you watch
Terminator 2 Judgment Day you rewatch
die hard you watch the these characters
fighting these villains are like how the
hell is the heroes supposed to defeat
the villain in this situation and again
throughout the film I I never felt that
live and felt that sense and that's what
you have to have an Avengers films
because that's why they're all coming
together it's got to be end of the world
and threat level menacing and that's a
big deal is that tonot you don't like a
trailer is not spoiler filled which is
cool I mean it does have Scarlet Witch
and we're winning with uh with Ultron
baits not that's part of the early part
of the play yeah like they don't reveal
what the the death of Quicksilver
watching this trailer is interesting
because the way they set up Ultron is
kind of similar to how I feel like
Thanos is being set up you know he wants
to take over he's gonna kill the
Avengers he's a philosophical type of
villain really just like the Russo
brothers are always different kinds of
filmmakers then Joss Whedon yes I
imagine infinity war will actually honor
that darkness I hope so I mean rusev
Brothers Avengers movies have not
exactly beat films if it's not then you
and I are bringing the Kleenexes into
the alright guys well that's our
trailers revisited for age of Ultron
check it out if you haven't check it out
if you haven't if not we've ruined a
good amount of the movie for you sorry
good yeah what other trailers do you
think would be worth revisiting right
now I mean we do this weekly so please
leave your comments down below Andrew
thank you for being here you guys can
check out Andrew on the movie source
channel fantastic YouTube channel
seriously guys go check it out you can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bellow so this
but it means something and I check out
our patreon now full-length TV show
reactions over there our weekly Q&A is
would love to have you become a patron
oject today all goes to support the
channel do it people